[Music]
for everybody's listening i do think
that there's incredible ways to
have business partnerships but i think
it's about being the bigger woman and
bigger man and having empathy and always
always always coming from the other
person's point of view
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
internation how are you super exciting
podcast uh today is one of those special
episodes where i get to go in depth with
a new business you know me uh i pretty
much want to open a new business every
day of my life
but this one has a real special feeling
as a matter of fact if you go to
vcrgroup.com right now if you're not
walking dog or working out or on a
flight uh if you can go to it
vcrgroup.com
that is the new hospitality restaurant
group that i'm starting with david
radalitz excuse me and josh capon
uh
chef josh capon
you'll see the heart in our logo and and
that's how i feel about this one this
one would be the devastation of my life
if it's not successful because i
i've been in business for a long time i
have incredible partnerships obviously
i've mainly been in my business with my
dad my brother
um but
this one feels so so so right so i'm
very excited to
uh introduce them to my broader
community through this podcast we're
going to go into
where the hospitality industry is what's
going on with postcovid restaurant life
the new york scene and a little bit of
like origin story comic book number one
with these two gentlemen so first let's
start with david roddle it's roddy as
you're known by the people that care
about you why don't you tell the vayner
nation a little bit about yourself
forget about what we're doing vcr group
we're talking about that grew up in long
island like talk to me about you
super excited to be here thank you gary
i
grew up in long island as you mentioned
been entrepreneurial my entire life
worked at the local bowling alley
delivered pizza just always found a way
to
stay active and try to make money and um
i liked putting in time to something and
seeing some sort of result it was a cool
connection for me
so
uh
in the height of you working at the
bowling alley
what was the 17
my dad
my dad was actually and kpon could
attest to this my dad's like a
renaissance man and everything he does
he does very
and
he used to go to that bowling alley that
that i worked at we lived down the
street from a bowling alley and my dad
was bowling 300s
perfect scores 300s yes perfect scores
when he was 15 years old insane it was
insane so i
would you say here on the show right off
the bat that your dad is a better man
than you
yeah my dad is definitely a better man
than me
um
but that's a that's a different topic
thank you we'll put you on the couch and
have that episode in a couple of months
all right and so
how did your kind of professional
hospitality food career start what was
the first seed of that i mean the first
seed of that was i used to rent out team
clubs when i was in high school i would
get everybody in our high school all the
seniors and juniors to get excited about
going to manhattan i would rent a bus
i would sell tickets
i would then bring them to these
alcohol-free places
everyone would think it would it was the
best night of their life i started
there'll be alcohol at these alcohol
free
you know
don't answer that question roddy don't
answer that question no alcohol i
understand and
yeah it was just it was cool it was it
was entrepreneurial nobody was doing it
uh you know the prom scene in long
island was a big deal when we were
growing up and there were these after
parties after prom in manhattan and that
was a big that was a big event
um
so that was the first start of it and
then in college i started an event
planning company
i became like the social chair of the
entire
greek life of university of maryland i
would plan people's data parties their
food
and it was just it was something that
came natural me i've always been a
social person i enjoyed interacting with
people at scale
vendors venues
guests clients
it was just fun for me
and that just continued to segue into
the next thing i then created a
nightlife marketing promotions company
in manhattan as i graduated college we
owned and operated lounges bars and
nightclubs
then that segwayed into restaurants and
hospitality i met chef alex dupac in my
late 20s
figured that was a good time to try to
be able to
hey dustin does it sound like roddy is
giving this interview in the woods with
crickets and frogs
um it sounds okay to me
really
yeah we'll keep it going i hear i hear
crickets
yeah maybe listen as long as dustin
thinks it's good
i mean the crickets are on fire
[Laughter]
you know roddy it's interesting by the
way hold on we didn't even introduce
yeah you know i
our roots run deep and we're both a
couple of turfs from university of
maryland which is kind of cool um i was
cooking for everybody in the greek life
and he was organizing the parties in all
the greek life but you were there like
20 years before ronnie was there right
wow wow
i also i also was there for a much
abbreviated time because some of us
didn't last the four years and had to
get them out of there before they died
um but but the truth is hey by the way
died is slang for kicked out of school
for [ __ ] grace nobody got kicked out of
school all right my parents pulled me
out before that happened
and i made them a short decision at a
young age to transfer to culinary school
where where my true passion lie because
every job i've had since i was 14 years
old was in a bakery a dishwasher a line
cook i invented the everything bagel but
going back to our lives
i
did i am going on record i invented the
everything bagel at pomona hot bagels
the owner of the bagel place looked at
me said stop playing around i said no
i'm telling you i'm off or something
over here and then three weeks later
david bagel's introducing everything
bagel fact it's not on google you don't
need to look it up it looks like david
yeah david from david's bagels claims he
invented it three blocks down the street
hold on sometime around 1980. that
you're not listening to me how old were
you it all lines up i was 14 years old
it all makes sense
it's a true story i couldn't make that
up if i tried
i love you i don't
i love you i don't think
okay well you were eight i was eight
working at the bagel shop he just said
fourteen that's fourteen david's biggest
biggest candy stole my bagel point is
and what i organized have you ever had
this conversation with david gustin we
don't talk because he knows he stole he
stole my magic formula i'm gonna find
him
with tape on he stole your ip is that
what you're saying and when you're eight
years old that's why you should have put
the bagel on the blockchain and then if
he did because nobody can steal it well
back then unfortunately there was no
blockchain
um but ronnie what i was going to say
was after my prom i organized the whole
the whole high school to go to the
afterparty limelight remember limelight
of course
of course people were so pissed the next
day i was getting threatening like how
dare you we party in the church i'm like
listen it was it was it was the hottest
club in new york city at the time i led
you to the promised land everybody
doesn't know you have this beat
listen don't start all right don't start
you just [ __ ] dropped
i invented everything mango i said it
once i'll say it again it's a true story
i was there when it happened called
prussian my best friend he's rattled
this by the way he's [ __ ] just cousin
as well he's back
wait a minute
your best friend is rodol it's his
cousin how crazy is that
it's like second cousins but we found
this out about a month ago
josh called me at like 11 30 at night
with on conference with his best friend
and his best friend explaining to me
that his dad or mom
is
my uncle once removed and yeah we're
like related
dad this is all this is all the sheriff
this is all meant to be this was in the
stars a long time ago wow
all right
let's keep going i'm still stuck on
listen this podcast is finished
everybody go to vcrgroup.com that's
that's what we could see yeah well like
this everything bagel thing i'm not
gonna let it go is it true it's true
story i was 14 years old i literally i
was making the bagels and one day you
would have to put sesame or poppy or
onion or salt and i said to stella who
owned the bacon i said i have an idea
let's put everything on the bagel and
she yelled at me she stopped playing
games i needed
i said stella well it was like gusting
and like the back room heard it and did
like i don't understand shut it down
look this guy david gustin looks like a
nice guy he came in he came in to check
on what was going on and i think he
heard over her in the conversation he
went back to david's bagels do you have
a real beef with custom i don't have any
beef i have no people nobody really nice
guy okay
is that david from david bagels by the
way yes this is ian told you this is
custom and i said listen
right you have to keep up yeah
it's so new
it's not it was interesting yeah
anyway
okay
so k-pop you're a celebrity chef
speaking of which i have a bag of
everything flagles over there i'm not
pleased yes we're gonna do a little
smoked salmon everybody on the podcast
if you were listening in on the facebook
uh live audio we did i've already
announced that i ate way too much food
they were over last night we had we had
a board meeting i'm not doing board
meetings anymore with this group
because
per night you have here's the deal so
you have no self-control gary no
self-control
roddy thank you you have no you have no
self-control it's not true fully
moderate life is about moderation i'm in
moderation i don't eat for the whole day
and then for dinner i go to town and if
you're going to put caviar bellini's in
front of me i'm going to eat right now
all of them if i put six out you're
gonna eat six correct if i put 50 out
you're gonna eat 50. that's right so now
i'm gonna have to only give you four
okay meanwhile
you can and can we put rodney on you the
crickets are bothering me meanwhile
you've never seen somebody happier than
kpon last night watching me eat
everything not just everything but not
only do you like everything bagels you
like humans that eat everything yes
listen when i we listen so so
you know gary rented out to the hamptons
david and i came out because we had a
couple podcasts to do which is very nice
we spent a wonderful night together i
got out here i'm cooking all day long
watching these guys do their thing while
i'm doing my thing but then i said 7 30
cameras go off computers go down i'm
making fresh pineapple margaritas i got
shrimp cocktail caviar believes and from
that point on carrick did not stop
eating i gave him a 16 ounce veal chop
and at one point he was gnawing on the
bone where i literally had to say gary
have you seen my hot ones episode please
check out hot google hot ones garyvee i
eat things to the bone because that's
the problem
into the bone like a dog
[Laughter]
listen man what what what what's missing
in the hospitality group that we're
bringing to the table like what why
should we exist
i i'm i'm muted or you hear me you're
loud go ahead
i think i think innovation i think
creativity and innovation
you know generally does not exist i
think this industry has been left behind
so
i think you know we're going to bring
that to create very thoughtful guest
experiences that are
that are amazing for people
okay but what about someone i don't want
i don't want to you know i don't want to
disrespect anybody that's currently in
the hospitality business um because look
there's a ton of great [ __ ] there's a
ton of stuff great stuff going on
roddy's
no but i mean i i i just think we're
gonna approach things a little
differently you know our our mission
statement or or or what vcr stands for
is old world hospitality meets new world
technology and obviously between roddy
and i and what we bring to the table i
wouldn't win the old we bring you
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty current and
when gary brings to the table there's
going to be some real leverages there'll
be some real innovation and we're going
to approach things differently and
honestly i just think there's going to
be a lot of empathy and i know you have
a wine company called empathy wine i
sold it which which is done very well
but i just i just think the fact that
even the fact that we're all here in
this house
that we that you invited us out
it just i think that's going to and we
want to treat everybody on our team as
friends starting with starting with them
let me jump in here i think this has
been very big conversation behind the
scenes and i know my audience that
listens to this podcast so many of you
know me you know how much i talk about
kindness this that the other thing
listen i
i think i've told both of you this i
have a new book coming out in november
that is very hardcore around emotional
intelligence and i think you know you
bring it up again here so i want to go
right behind i want to take the curtain
away because i want to bring value to
this podcast you know i know everybody
who's listening to this is going to
visit we see our restaurants once we
open that that's not about that's not
the punchline here for me i want people
to learn or get an insight what has been
very big for me and you and i even again
the way you delivered the sentence i
know where you were going
this whole notion that the hospitality
industry is a high-intensity business
because people that aren't the best if
you think about it a chef at her or his
best
is
often
one of two things or when i think
they're iconic two of two things which
is one an actual artist from a culinary
standpoint of the food
and then
if they're really specialists where i
think this is why i wanted to be in
business with you mr capon
also a front of the house maestro and
makes people really want to be there
both of those put incredible
subconscious or even obvious pressure on
everyone around them to support that
unfortunately and we talked about this
last night after i put 800 pounds into
me i talked to you about a thing that
happened to me recently that was very
intense and i was kind of talking about
how when i'm at my most upset with my
team i go into a cocoon i don't want
them to be affected by it and i almost
go into this like kind of [ __ ] cocoon
process come back out and ready to deal
to the point where one time i left wine
library
were in my 20s and went to sleep at 4
p.m in the afternoon because that's how
deep the cocoon had to be because that's
how devastating the situation was and we
were talking about and and i think
anybody listening right now and they've
seen the hell's kitchen and the like
there's a culture that sometimes isn't
kind enough by the three of us standards
to the people and i think
we were very passionate about standing
that up yes 100
people going to see the vcr group logo
if you go to bcr group.com right now
you'll see the logo and there's a
purposely a heart in our logo
of course we mean that for everybody
who's listening now we want to love the
living [ __ ] out of you when you come to
our restaurants
but i think for all three of us it was a
thing it was a secret wink to we want to
love
the
first day on the first job entry-level
job in our shops
i think that's good
i think that's going to be in the
restaurant business the people who work
for us and with us are called family and
i think when you're treated like real
family because we spend a tremendous
amount of time and hours and holidays
and weekends together you got to treat
these people respect because bottom line
if your career is taking care of
everybody else you better make sure that
you
wherever it is that you're working you
know and also just most important i
think
being valued and understanding what your
strengths are um in terms of anything
what you do on a day-to-day basis i mean
you have to stay true to who you are and
people around you need to understand
that as well and i tell the story when
we solidify this deal um when the three
of us came together a weekend in miami
and we were sitting around the table
together and my wife was always by my
side because she's my partner in crime
and in life and gary looked to me and
said you know okay bun please make sure
your wife is always at these meetings
going forward because you're over there
thinking about the lobster rolls that
you're gonna make for lunch and she's
taking care of all the business end and
the truth is i was thinking about the
lobster
life but more importantly the fact that
you understood that and knew where my
head was at was something i'll never
forget because that's who i am and
yesterday when i got to this house and i
was preparing dinner for five hours and
rodney is to my right crushing calls
left and right and organizing a website
and i'm listening to you over here to my
left doing what you do best and i just
felt so comfortable doing what i'm doing
because it comes down to dirty it's like
all right guys let's eat let's have some
fun because that's what i do and i think
that's the most important valuable
lesson that people need to understand i
think for everybody who's listening and
i'll let ronnie jump in add some color
commentary
what's really interesting i've never had
a starting point with i'm trying to
think well actually not true well
different empathy i had two partners
john trauman and nate schroeder we had
an incredibly
blitz of a business with empathy with
this very successful exit to
constellation brands
but they weren't my equals they were my
minority partners they grew up being my
interns and became my partners which is
in a lot of ways a better story than
this is but a different story but i've
never been in a situation where i go in
where you have an equal partnership in a
lot of ways and
what's really interesting is
i think when you have three cooks in the
kitchen you have none and i'm very
scared of business partnerships
but
what's interesting for me and i i hope
to talk about this in 10 years
in my business life
after we successfully create this stance
i do think that self-awareness and over
communication give you a prayer and
different skill sets and everybody truly
understand listen we are gonna have our
days right like you know it's really
funny i'm interesting because i'm an
operator people you know a lot of people
are confused because they see the map
some people think i'm a motivational
speaker some people think i'm a mascot
i've operated every business i've ever
run so things that i've been involved
with a little more passively or even
vayner x companies
where i'm not the driver because i'm the
driver of vaynermedia but harwood's the
driver of gallery or james orsini of
sasha or avery she drives vayner nft
i'm so empathetic to the operator
because i remember when i was in my
dad's business i was the operator and
when he would come out of left field and
not have the context it drove me crazy
it devastated me so much too that i'm
petrified like i already know how i'm
gonna act in our board meetings or at
the restaurant like i'm gonna have
passions i think i know what i'm doing
but i'm not close enough i have to be in
a lot of ways the one c
in our relationship and then there's
gonna be other things that i i'm about
and i think that's self-awareness and i
think for everybody's listening i do
think that there's incredible ways to
have business partnerships but i think
it's about being the bigger woman and
bigger man and having empathy and always
always always coming from the other
person's point of view as an african new
book that i have coming up i have this
scenario i talk about in the book
of accountability when your partner
steals money from you and how you can
actually
continue from that and even by rodney's
response everyone who's listening that's
a 99
death blow in a partnership 99
and i talk about is it like how'd you
get there maybe if you weren't
not interested in not looking at the
number like you know it's i'll leave
that for another day but robbie thoughts
yeah no i think everything you said is
is 100 right i think vcr group the
common thread of caring about people and
taking care of one another and just
being a good dude and and having that be
um the foundation of the group is is the
most important and then i think each one
of us do something that's completely
different and complementary to one
another that we can lean on each other
and not step on each other's toes so i
feel very comfortable in the in the
business realm and and keep being our
our plays and i know that i have you
know your support gary we're on text all
day we're on you know so many different
live conversations and zooms but you're
giving me the confidence to really run
with it and from a culinary standpoint
and a branding standpoint and a
personality standpoint um and content
creation i don't think there's anybody
better than kpon so
i feel
extremely confident doing what i'm doing
because i'm able to
rely on you guys and the things i need i
think we each leverage one another
really well and then i think there's a
collaborative effort that when we're
sitting in a room or having a bottle of
wine and talking through what we want do
we want to touch that project do we not
want to do this i think ultimately it
always yields the right decision um
we're fully transparent we're honest
with one another there's nothing hidden
and we respect everybody so i think the
most important part and there's
obviously mixed you know people think
differently about this but we all care
about each other we're all friends
that's how this was birthed um we didn't
come out of leftion and say let's just
do a business together gary and i have
been friends for 10 years cape and i've
been friends for 20 years you know we've
all watched each other's careers gary
you've supported me on a previous
business venture that's gone well so i i
think that there's um already momentum
of um of a relationship uh we know what
we all stand for and now we're finding
our strengths together as a team to
bring value to people keep on i i want
to add one thing
you can't over communicate i don't i
don't think you can over communicate i
think you need to be honest
and transparent especially in
relationships both business and personal
because then you'll never find yourself
in a position where your business
partner's stealing from you that's right
um as far as you know the three of us i
think you know to quote the movie one of
my favorite movies of the girl next door
where a tripod
josh how many movies do you watch not
that many there's an old movie with a
rainbow if you haven't seen it but we
are a tripod
there's three legs
i know what's in the tripod for
everybody's listening
to the movie
by the way this has been the best part
of vcr group
like kpon references three movies a day
i've watched three movies in my life and
the disconnect is
astonishing yet we still love each other
talk to me about
not to over brag a little bit here and
and rodney can go on you because it
resets your crickets
um but maybe people by the way on the
record dustin said that they can't hear
the crickets or he can't so we'll see if
it translates i think it brings a nice
ambiance to the episode if they can but
when did you
cross when did you realize you were
crossing into a little bit of like
celebrity chef land because you have
it's not like you're the biggest
celebrity chef but i want to touch on
this a little bit like you've won a
bunch of burger bashes correct me if i'm
wrong you did have a tv show at some
point or at least a pilot or a dinner
one season or maybe you'll correct i
actually don't fully know but um you're
incredibly adored in the new york scene
you're known
broader i'm just more this is a little
bit of like getting to know
all of us a little bit for this audience
when did you know your your career is
going you're starting to make some noise
as an executor you're doing well as a
chef when did it start crossing into
broader awareness like when was the
first time more people heard of you was
it a page six mention did you win a
competition i just actually don't know
this which is why it's fun for me when's
the first time you got a little more
broad awareness
i'm trying to remember that moment in
time myself it's not it's not so clear
to me to be honest uh you know the term
celebrity chef is still something yeah
that that's foreign to me in a way let's
call you an influencer i i do know that
i am very comfortable which most chefs
are not listen the chef is technically a
back of the house position means they
want to be in the back of the house they
don't want to be engaging with people
they don't want to be around people
right um i definitely wrote that mold
you know i followed the amber lagasse
and bobby and some guys like that like
all right and educator because those are
obviously names that a lot of people
listening right now
may be more familiar with once they
became tv stars where those guys in
their restaurants also very front of the
house are they very you know
so but i'm not quite sure but i look i
also know when i started lore when we
opened the lord i was running around the
dining room you know how old were you
when when you opened up
so that's uh
is it is it 2010
2002 it was about 15 16 years ago but
even before i look i was in matthew's i
was in alva like i was always in the
dining room but i do remember when we
opened the floor it was a big deal as a
new restaurant and my partners at the
time i was touching tables i knew every
table in the room i'm dropping little
amuse bushes right get from the chef
whatever it may be and i remember the
two of them looking at me like they said
to me shouldn't you be in the kitchen
i said guys first of all number one i
would never expose myself to the dining
room if food was taking too long the
food wasn't coming out good and hot like
i know that i have a team you have to
trust your team in the back my executive
chef my line goes to execute my certain
step and i'm just going to put on a show
out here and give people a reason to
come back and all of a sudden it went
from shouldn't you be in the kitchen to
capable
okay do me a favor say hello to my
friends on table 14 16 18
and and you know when when you would
come in with whoever it may be and with
another couple and i'm at the table and
i'm dropping some eggs or doing this i'm
putting on the show the other couple
always says to me hey can we come back
here with our friends and will you do
this little yeah you know
the the dance
the thing you know can we get some
deviled eggs okay if that's going to
give you a reason to come back and spend
money in this restaurant you're damn
sure the roi of those deviled eggs with
seven caviar little eggs
right rodney
give us a little behind the curtain guys
as you know restaurateurs that have had
success like you know the nuances the
glass of champagne the hello the
the the free dessert the
the you know the offense there's defense
everybody let me just set this up
there's definitely defense right all of
us that are listening have had something
go wrong and this and that and you
always watch i'm a businessman so i've
always been curious of
mistakes happen what do people do about
the mistake do they go crazy over the
top do they nail it right down the pike
do they underperform because there's
audacity i always watch that we all have
probably at this point if you're
listening had uh you know because that's
what's hard about the hospitality
business something go awry and and and
you know let's call it what it is eight
out of ten places will come through with
something to me but but i've always been
fascinated with the offense yeah
nothing's gone wrong but the place is
just trying to really get you there
you know what's the mentality of that
what what have you been actually let's
make this fun tell me
something a restaurant did let's give
you know one thing we've talked about
behind the scenes is being one of the
best engines for other restaurant tours
right like like like just being really
friendly and pro other places other for
we all have so many friends in the
business
let's give a shout out right now to
someone both of you i'm i'm going
long-winded here to give you a couple
minutes to think
tell me about very specific experience
of a place that really caught you
and caught your mind your heart your
feelings on a very good offensive move
what comes to mind ronnie you go first
oh wow
um
i'm gonna say my buddy john meadow
uh who is the
proprietor uh ceo of ldv hospitality
um they own scarpetta and a bunch of
other properties and
just the touches from handwritten notes
to a thoughtful glass of champagne my
wife and i went to scarpetta it's one of
our first nights out during covid we sat
outside it was freezing out but they
built a beautiful ski chalet
and there was you know a perfect glass
of champagne to start the night with a
handwritten note from john he wasn't
able to be there but he wanted me to
know that he was appreciative that i was
there and he wanted to wish us a happy
anniversary
i think those thoughtful
moments you know of something that
i'm not gonna say that it's
insignificant from a cost standpoint to
a restaurant but it is something they're
giving away for free i think if you
intelligently do
a comp or we called it a fluff item at
empeon you could really change people's
experiences which is what i love
i think though that the fluff or the you
know the comp or whatever you want to
call it if done wrong could also bring a
meal the wrong way you know a lot of
people just crush you on dessert and do
an unthoughtful fluff
and maybe they're not really thinking
about the guest or the table or the
health restrictions or you know maybe
they're on a diet you have to look at
what somebody you know how they interact
how they look at the menu how they're
eating how they're ordering
the situation right you're watching
you're you're watching you're trying to
film the gap
and bring them somewhere they that
they're not able to get to themselves
maybe you hear them talk about a dish
and they're interested but they didn't
order it maybe they're price sensitive
to it so there's a lot of ways to do a
fluff that i feel like
it gives you incredible power to change
somebody's night but it also done the
wrong way
can be awkward some people don't want to
leave a good word on the table right
right how about when when somebody just
drop something on the table never
bothers to say
hey this is a little something from the
shop
you don't know if you're supposed to eat
it or not because we didn't order it
nobody told you it was a free or a cop i
i always eat it immediately yes and when
they come back oh i'm like oh yeah
you know i just got a little free
broccoli rob
[Laughter]
okay but how about for you
um specific thing well
this is impossible i always trade my
staff by the way this doesn't sound like
the starting point of a specific anybody
coming to the restaurant
full metal jacket
anybody can come into the restaurant
have a lovely experience right you can
always have a monthly experience but one
thing i always train my staff if
somebody comes in and something goes
wrong
you have the chance to go above and
beyond
to really make it a much more memorable
experience
obviously you could just say hey sorry
went wrong but you're gonna
above and beyond to to the point where
they say you know answer the question
you know i think for me listen my wife
um my wife is gluten dairy free but she
loves good food she loves good food so
so very often we go into the restaurant
the first thing i said is so hey you
know she glued in there
and what i don't want that to ever
happen by the way is to diminish
my experience right i don't care you're
basically just waiting is this video
because i am not i don't even notice but
i am not gluten and dairy free and i
don't want to see that i don't want to
suffer because so you're basically wing
playing bro like hey same thing with
mike bring her stuff for me drink her
stuff don't not bring the bread basket
because she's gluten free we'll figure
it out but i think michael white a very
dear friend of mine one of the best
chefs
we celebrated we celebrated uh three
birthdays in a row with with lori and
maria and because you know when we sit
down and the first thing i say the
waiter is she's she's gluten they're
free and this is like home of the best
pasta in the world
because of michael white yes and he goes
chef white has this all under control
sit back relax enjoy the ride and not
only is she eating the best gluten-free
pasta courses but so am i and then the
cake comes out and there was always two
one gluten free so i just think just
know just being knowing ahead of time
that not only is my wife gonna be taken
care of because
my wife who i love very much she
knows right ground control to major tom
anyway more importantly my wife is being
taken care of but i know that the big
guy over here is gonna be wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute this makes
me beg the question
did you invent the everything bagel
gary it is on record that in 1986
i invented them everything bagel at
pomona hot bagels working with stella my
best friend jason prussian was a witness
and then david from david's bagel stole
it within weeks later and i'm sure if
you happen to google who would bend to
the everything bagel his name is gonna
come up not mine
roddy what um
what what i have a good one so i think
the vayner nation is a bunch of very
very very kind people
for fun i'm actually i actually again do
not know i have a guess of what the
answer is
hot take
what is something that
customers do
that is a pet peeve of restaurants
from like like maybe you're not i think
ever i'm sure the answer is showing up
late for a rez but
educate us on a funny one forget about
the obvious like being incredibly rude
to the staff is there like i'm actually
being very selfish right now i'm scared
that i do something
that i don't like going through my life
as an immigrant first generation my
parents were very insular i had to like
learn things like i was always very good
at tipping so that never got scary
you know i'll give you a good one
somewhere along the line in my 20s one
of my friends said you're not leaving a
tip for the you know the people that
were cleaning the room i'm like what are
you talking about like completely
baffled i'm like whoa you know now at
that thank god at that point i've been
in like 10 hotel rooms in my life now
it's like 10 a week now i know but like
i never i never knew that was a thing
so you know forget about late forget
about rude rooted staff forget about no
tip things that are like so easy is
there a subtle one
you wanna go first you've got one
you know
what up roddy apologize
like kpop usually needs to tell a story
that has nothing to do with the answer
the fact he has two answers i need to
hear them go i'm going to tell the story
before you even god dog
two of my biggest pet peeves are when
people ask for salt before they even
taste the food like if you go out for
dinner and you know we rule number one
as a chef or even if you're cooking at
home you never you never serve anything
to anybody without tasting it yourself
say never like that again never you
never taste it now is that a n-e-double
b-a yeah okay
with an exclamation point you never and
you have to get the grunt in your mind
you never serve anything without tasting
yourself i mean if if i'm watching my
cooks be on the line and they're not
tasting things before they serve them i
don't really taste properly because you
are going out to eat incredible food
that you should not have to season
yourself because sprinkling salt that
was probably that soul shaking for a
year with the rice in there though wait
a minute why would we have salt are we
gonna have a bcr group no no no we're
not gonna have to okay we'll say but
more importantly you can't season food
properly okay written that's a good one
i love it i have a short sex you know
taste of food before you guys next this
is a selfish question i don't even care
about the listeners at this point i
never do that next what's the other one
number two uh i was most recently
involved in the steakhouse and one of my
biggest pet peeves is somebody orders a
steak medium rare right you you get it
they ask you to cook it no you get it
you get it you spend time cooking this
thing
an animal an animal gave its life
forward it's an expensive piece
you you probably cook you let it rest
and then the server comes back with the
steak and they literally cut a little
piece off the end of the steak and they
say this is overcooked
well you know how about you cut into the
middle of steak and one thing that i can
get away with that because you're a
k-pop i am a k-pop i saw you do this so
i know you're about to go you come back
out and you fight i don't fight you
fight for the right awareness right
you're fighting for the right i'm
fighting for this animal who gave his
life because first of all
you probably have fun you gotta fight
for your right
most importantly it's dark in dining
rooms so you don't see the
lighting
not good every dining room is dark
you're never going to see what i see
real quick we're not going to have
shitty salt and we will have good
lighting and and you can't cut into the
end of the steak and i very i would
always cut into the middle of the steak
and show you i'm like there's a perfect
medium rare i go back back down
i go back out with the customer and my
pleasure so listen how many times
i would say along those lines sometimes
customers or a lot of the times excuse
me
would complain about their food after
they ate it
and
no that's a good one
some i don't know if it's they're
looking for it to be calmed but they
literally eat three quarters of a dish
we always
we always took the high road but if you
didn't like it we're happy to make you
something else or we're happy to take it
off your check or we're happy to do both
but when they say they don't enjoy it
they eat the majority of it and then
bring it up after it makes you feel like
they're taking advantage of our group
can we take a selfie with that person on
the spot and post it on our social
calling
three quarters club
the other pet peeves and i you know i've
never seen anybody do that but by
generally i think social media is is
tremendously beneficial for restaurants
you know beautiful food imagery all that
you know people being ambassadors on
your behalf that being said
you know a lot of people will sit there
and just take pictures of the food you
know try to get ideal lighting you know
and do this whole thing for the first
you know four to five minutes after a
dish drops and that could really change
the quality or the enjoyment
i know you don't like hearing that
gallery but you like hearing that's like
a good one right like it's steaming
especially for a very hot dish you give
up those first four or five minutes our
goal as a chef is to get that food out
of the new right to the minute in front
of you as soon as possible even i know
sushi restaurants you know even even
with the nori with the nori with the
hand roll where it says crisp and you're
taking the light and people are doing
the poor sushi chef was like please just
eat it let's go let's go around let's go
speed round to get to know roddy and
kate bottom and ask you a bunch of
questions one take answers sugar babies
here we go
favorite
sushi
like the actual like fish what's your
favorite sushi piece all right listen i
think you got a pink one it's victorious
what is your favorite starting beverage
if you're having a real night like
friday saturday like a couple or like
friends like what will be my birthday's
work what's your one more day to play
come on everybody get your roller skates
today all right it's saturday i i think
i first yeah i think no not for service
like you yours is not champagne i got it
i mean this is so easy i've done julio
in 1942 on the rocks but i think a glass
of chicken
everybody that knows me knows how i feel
about the rock it's a it's a terra mana
reposado chilled it's it's an amazing
tequila big fan love it
first choice for dessert
on average your highest ratio which
dessert you pick
chocolate mousse cake from wolf gangs
it's got the oreo crust with the schlog
on the side
epic it's like a splurge for me my wife
makes up for me at home on big
celebrations always it's a go-to
there's no way i'm only ordering one
dessert it doesn't happen i can't stand
tables i you know yeah you want to go
back to the other question by the way go
back to the other question you know what
i hate when four people or six people
order one dessert with five spoons you
know what i say go [ __ ] yourself and go
grab some ice cream around the corner
because i need your table back my mom
used to do that bring this one dessert
with four spoons i'm like no bring us
every dessert with five spoons like um
for me you just you
you on a different i don't know if you
did on this podcast or a facebook live
you just [ __ ] on me for moderation and
now you just told the world if you don't
eat a shitload of dessert i'm upset with
you can you pick one
i i think you have to order multiple
desserts you can't order one dessert
because the pastry chef can you answer
your questions
ice cream sandwich okay very nice
uh by the way i went through a year of
my life where the chip which every time
i walk home from work true story i know
he's not healthy i love that ronnie
johnny
ronnie roddy one the world comes like
the the god of food comes down and she
says to you roddy i've chosen you
to pick
the type of food new york city can now
only have one type one genre one type of
food what do you pick for the for your
sushi sushi okay
you are you are asking tough questions
you are asking very tough i know i'm
just gonna answer
what genre food category food do you
does new york city now all restaurants
is italian is it greek is it sushi like
you gotta answer strawberries
italian and really good
chinese so just saying
you are a big fan of chinese challenge
what would you say you are a big fan of
chinese we had dinner we had dinner guys
we had dinner two weeks ago with a new
potential business partnership we flew
these guys into town we're having a big
celebratory dinner myself josh gary are
there we're going to an awesome greek
restaurant next door to that restaurant
is a chinese restaurant a very good
chinese restaurant
k-pon who is supposedly very
uh hospitable and caring for other
operators
did not care that i got this reservation
booked did not care that they hooked us
up with a beautiful table
well hello
you wanted me to cancel it on the spot
while after we checked in and you wanted
to call a blitz and go next door and
crush chinese food not a blitz it was
called an audible and who we supposed to
be taking care of that night we were
supposed to be taking care of our
clients that flew into dinner i where
did they want to eat ronnie where did
they want to eat there were a couple
chefs where did they want him
they were peer pressured by you because
you screamed at everybody
gary overruled the whole thing and at
the end of the day by the way i don't
know if you heard it's vcr yes at the
end of the day the greek restaurant was
the right call but our our friends
chinese restaurants
i think they got 100
all right
final final final question
one
word
to describe what the vcr group is gonna
bring to the world k-pon
one word one
he's not capable of one word yes he is
one word roddy you'll go first kpon
needs a lot of time one word
what creativity
creativity
i go love
love
boys i'm very excited to be in business
with you i can't wait to have you back
on once we've got some meat on the bone
pun intended
and open up our shoulder meat on the
bone i know we should have a picture of
the veal chop bone last night that had
no blocks
i put in work proper work
ronnie you want to say something
love you brother vcr dot com please
check it out if you've got business
development opportunities rather
roddy literally lives for the emails
that come through the forum lives for
them he takes screenshots and he's like
i can't believe this person albania
wants to see guys just email me directly
it all flows to me anyway david vcr
group.com do not bother emailing kpon do
not email bother emailinggary just come
direct to me a hollow back drink a hole
do not pass go do not collect 200
by the way if you have any cooking
questions you can you can email me
directly at kpon at vcr group.com and
tune into our instagram feed as well as
our tick tock feed we're having a lot of
fun producing some really quality
content entertaining educational and
engaging all at the same time uh my
parting thoughts are with the reference
kpon mate there's nobody listening to
this podcast that can beat me in
monopoly thank you for listening vcr
group i love you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you